don't most people report if you were to
ask them how do you think they would say
I think in words they love people do
although remember a lot of people know
what a lot of people say that they think
in images that they think in body
sensations I think that what you're
aware of is probably a tip of the
iceberg as to what's actually happening
in the mind and words are the things
that we can talk to each other about
them and how am I going to tell you what
I'm thinking unless I use words yes and
so the the thing that's going to be most
uppermost in my mind if I'm trying to
convey to you how I think are going to
be things like the the vocalizations
these the auditory imagery of words and
that's what we notice although I don't
think that's what we're the the real
heart of the matter is in thought
processes I think that's just the part
that's most accessible to us in other
words it's a consequence of the accident
that we were born with mouths instead of
multimedia projector systems exactly we
use we use our our mental imagery of
words I think to as a 1xtra like almost
like a piece of paper that we jot down a
phone number to remember it but of
course all inside our heads